- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to talk about cities.
Today, more than 50% of
the world's population
lives in a city, and this
percentage grows every year
because of something called urbanization.
Urbanization is the creation
and growth of cities,
human settlements with
higher population densities
than rural areas.
The high population density in cities
has a lot of advantages.
Because people are closer together,
it's easier to coordinate
community efforts like recycling,
public education, and
public transportation.
Urban residents also tend
to have better access
to things like medical
care and family planning.
However, the high
population density of cities
also can have a negative
impact on the environment.
You can imagine, with so many people
living close together in one space,
it can cause a strain on the
natural resources of the area
and generate more air and water pollution.
Cities can use sustainable planning
to counter these effects.
Urban planners often talk about the ratio
between green space and
gray space in a city,
where the green spaces are
vegetation and the gray spaces
are things like buildings
and paved surfaces,
like roads and sidewalks and parking lots.
These gray spaces may be necessary,
but cities should be planned thoughtfully
to add some green spaces too.
When gray spaces dominate
a cityscape too much,
the paved surfaces prevent water
from seeping into the
ground, so when it rains,
it creates large amounts of runoff.
Having nowhere to go,
the water travels across paved surfaces,
picking up pollutants along the way.
All this runoff can
lead to flash flooding.
Adding more green spaces
can help prevent this from happening
because plants soak up water.
There are many creative
ways that urban planners
can add green spaces to our environment.
Some buildings in cities
grow plants on their roofs.
They're called green roofs.
The plants soak up the rain and
snow melt that hits the roof
and prevents it from
going into the street.
Also, plants create shade
and help cool things down,
so buildings with green roofs
wouldn't have to spend as much
energy on air conditioning.
Green spaces can also help the environment
by allowing for groundwater recharge,
which is allowing more water
to sink back into the ground
and replenish the aquifer.
Some cities do this by
building rain gardens,
which are gardens specifically designed
to filter water back into the ground,
the plants and the rain gardens
help filter pollutants in the runoff
and prevent the pollutants
from contaminating water ecosystems.
Cities can also help
with groundwater recharge
by building permeable
surfaces in their cities.
Parking lots can be constructed
with permeable paving to reduce runoff.
Groundwater recharge can
help prevent something
that happens in coastal cities
called saltwater intrusion.
Let's say that this city right
here is a city on the coast,
so it's really close to the ocean.
And let's say this city decides
to build a pump right here
to access the freshwater
in the aquifer below it.
But the city has a lot of people in it
and it needs a lot of water.
The city might end up taking
more and more freshwater
at a rate too fast for the freshwater
in the aquifer to replenish itself.
Pulling up so much fresh water
can create a space for the
saltwater in the nearby ocean
to come and take its place.
The saltwater from the ocean
would contaminate the freshwater supply,
making it unpotable.
But if this city decided to increase
the amount of permeable
surfaces and green spaces,
then when it rains, the water will be able
to seep back into the ground
and it would refill the empty space
the pump has created with freshwater.
This would mean that freshwater
would continually be replacing the water
that was taken out by the pump,
so saltwater intrusion couldn't happen.
Adding more green spaces could
also help with air pollution
because plants absorb carbon
dioxide and produce oxygen.
Cities produce most of
the world's air pollution.
Part of this is because of urban sprawl.
As cities become more populated,
they expand into suburban
areas and even exurban areas,
the areas past the suburbs.
All of that expansion leads people
to live farther away from their jobs.
This causes people to spend
a lot more time in their cars
on their long commutes to work.
And these long lines of cars
of people traveling to work
emit a lot of carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide is a greenhouse gas,
which means it retains heat from the sun,
and it contributes to climate change.
But carbon dioxide isn't the only kind
of air pollution that cities produce.
Emissions from motor vehicles
and industrial facilities in cities
can create something
called photochemical smog.
This is the kind of hazy, smoky pollution
that you can sometimes see
in the horizon line of cities
and it can be really
harmful to eyes and lungs.
So, how could urban
planners solve this problem?
Cities could cluster grocery stores,
offices, and homes closer together,
building up rather than out,
making buildings taller rather than wider.
This would mean that people
wouldn't have to travel as far
to get where they need,
so people could rely on walking or biking
rather than
fossil-fuel-consuming vehicles.
Cities can reduce vehicle emissions
by making public transportation
more convenient and affordable.
This would mean that fewer people
would need to use their
own cars to get around
and it would cut down on traffic.
Also, cities could build more paths,
sidewalks, and bike lanes
so people wouldn't have to rely
on fossil-fuel-consuming
vehicles to get around.
Encouraging walking and biking
could also improve the
health of city residents.
Cities can use clean forms of energy,
like solar or wind power,
to reduce air pollution.
They could also use fossil
fuels more effectively
through energy co-generation,
which is a way of using the heat
given off by the burning of fossil fuels,
not just the electricity.
By creating goals and sustainable plans,
cities can help reduce
air and water pollution
and increase the wellbeing
of their residents.
The city of Espoo in Finland, for example,
was recognized as a world
leader in energy sustainability
for its goal to become carbon
neutral by the year 2030.
Cities are centers for economic
development, innovation,
social and cultural diversity, and jobs.
With some urban planning,
cities can become centers
for sustainability too.